my name is Cyrus I'm a I'm a postdoc at
University of Chicago and I did my PhD
in programming languages I finished last
year at CMU and I'm really excited about
the future of programming environments I
think there's a lot of optimism about
what's going on in that area there's a
lot of cool ideas being put out on how
programming environments can help us
answer questions that we have while
we're programming how programming
environments can help us save times they
have a lot of the effort that we need to
do the kind of boilerplate stuff that I
think it's really annoying that that
takes up a lot of the time that that we
use when we're programming and prevents
us from doing the kind of stuff that we
really want to do solving the problems
that we want to solve addressing some of
the big challenges in society that we
want to address and so I'm going to
present some work today
which is all kind of wrapped up in this
project called hazel which is really
exploring sort of the the future of how
programming should feel and what hazel
is isn't it's an experimental
programming environment it's quite
experimental right now that that's
really trying to examine the theoretical
foundations the semantic foundations for
those feelings that we want to have so a
programming environment is a user
interface and on one side of that
interface is obviously a programmer or
in some cases many programmers working
together maybe on the same screen maybe
on different computers but what's on the
other side of that interface right what
are these two programmers here
interacting with so the naive answer
might be a program right but in fact
most in most programming environments
today that's not quite true most of the
time in fact we're mostly just
interacting with text and not all pieces
of text are programs unless you're using
APL which this cat is using
to become a program a piece of text
Esther run quite a gauntlet all right
you have to the first parts it comes the
parse tree and you type check it get a
type tree and then you run it and you
hope it doesn't crash crash prematurely
before it gets to the part of the
program that you're actually working on
or you're interested in so that you can
actually interact with that program and
on each leg of this gauntlet some text
doesn't make it make it to the next
slide and the implications of this are
that the various features the various
language services that your programming
environment provides to you through
various user interfaces these language
services they rely on these intermediate
representations and when they're not
when you don't get to that like at the
gauntlet you don't get these programming
services available to you for example
say you've written this text into your
into your editor well you haven't put
anything to the right of the plus it's
not well-formed and so it's just text
and the only services you have available
to you or the TextEdit services TextEdit
actions that your your editor provides
you with um so that so you know this
maybe you're just abut this is maybe the
very temporary state you're just about
the type of thing to the right of the
plus and so it's just you know a few
hundred milliseconds between when this
is true but there are other situations
where your program can be malformed for
quite a bit of time for example if
you're doing a big case analysis you
might write this and start filling in
the first case or whichever case you'd
like and leave the other ones blank and
from the perspective of the grammar of
the programming language this is
probably not well formed and so again
you don't get any of the editor services
while you're doing is potentially very
complicated tasks I'll talk about
workarounds for in a second but I just
wanted to make that point even if you
have a well-formed program say to the
right of the plus you've written F
because again you're about to apply F
but in that very moment it's just the
variable F which has function type well
it's well formed the parsers happy with
it but the type checker is not happy
with it because you can't add functions
to two numbers right so you'll get some
of these editor services like syntax
highlighting Auto formatting various
context-free tree transformations but
you won't get any of the editor services
that requires
romantic understanding of your program
again this might be really temporary but
there's other situations where it might
take a little longer before you get to
the next the next leg of the journey
right
you might just specify function f and
you haven't defined it yet and that
might take a little while before that's
done and then there's some situations
where it takes a long time before you
get back to a complete program think of
a large-scale refactoring you change
some really fundamental type definition
and your program and all of a sudden
hundreds of errors pop up in your
program and you spend two weeks going
and changing all those all those
definitions that you wrote well for two
weeks you're not going to have these
editor services available to you and
then finally let's say you have a well
type program well typically that means
you can run it but you might not be able
to run it as far as you'd like because
maybe you've kind of just like worked
around some of these limitations by
raising unimplemented in a certain point
in your program and so anything after
that point in the program evaluation
you'll never get to and so any live
programming services that you want to
use in that part of the program won't be
available to you right so it's like you
don't you don't get the full assortment
of language services in your programming
environment unless you have a complete
program and for the live programming
stuff one that doesn't fail prematurely
before you really want it to fail or are
an - at least right so so this we call
this the gap problem because there's
these gaps where you can have failure
occur and then you get these gaps in
service so let me put that in words real
quick the gap problem is language
services flicker out or report sometimes
little reports dáil information from
previous editor states when the program
is incomplete and so I want to talk real
quick about an approach that sort of is
a partial solution of the gap problem
which is typed holes what they do is
they allow you to like decrease the
number of editor States there are
informed RL typed by putting in holes
instead of leaving leaving spots blank
and so there's a number of languages and
eco language ecosystems now that are
kind of adopting typed holes and in both
the language and in the programming
environments for that language so for
example in GHC Haskell you can use this
underscore to the right of the + for
example and now
it's a well-formed term and it's also
well typed because underscore is kind of
typed like raising an exception you can
do the same thing with that case
analysis example you can give that typed
wholes name so if you put some
identifiers there after the underscore
that's the name of the whole similarly
in this map example and then the
programming environment say Emacs that
that you're using will report the
information that the compiler produces
which tells you that you have a whole it
tells you what it's type is and in
Pascal it tells you some other things
and then it'll it'll sometimes tell you
so it'll suggest some things to you so
there's some really cool work going on
and on suggestions for example a little
here it just tells you that there's some
relevant bindings like K and plus and
scope in this example and so yeah you're
getting some nice actually like editor
services that know about the types of
things here even though your program has
these blank spots in them but they're
not blank anymore so it's okay and so
there's a there's other programming
systems that have the same feel to them
one thing one that I want to talk about
is Agda this is the one that I was using
when I started really thinking about
holes and doing some proofs and what
Agda has it has these kind of these
empty holes that I just showed you from
Haskell and it also has these non empty
holes so egg does this dependently type
programming language people use it as a
proof assistant and you can when you
don't quite know what you want to do but
you know that you're gonna use a
variable like IH that's the induction
hypothesis and this proof you can put it
in this thing called a non empty hole
between these curly braces and Agda
knows how to parse that and knows how to
type check that and it gives you some
type information it tells you what the
goal type of that hole of that hole is
the type of the hole it tells you the
type that you actually have of this
expression in the hole and you can kind
of like look at those and see what the
difference is and try to figure out how
to fill the hole in the right way and
then you also get this context
information about what's in scope these
are sort of the assumptions that you
currently have into that point in your
proof so yeah so Agda has really good
support for this a lot of other
dependent ID proof assistants have have
similar features address and number of
others and so you know typed holes like
you like I said they're there apart
solution so like you could still write
this and this will still not parse and
GHC for example in in whatever language
this is right and but if you find
yourself in this situation you can spend
a little bit of your time before you get
to the thing you're not you're trying to
think about next putting a few
underscores in maybe that doesn't take
that much time and now it'll parse maybe
this isn't quite well typed yet though
because maybe X isn't a type that has
these cases and so you can use these non
empty holes and inactive for example and
put the X in this non empty hole now
it'll type check and you'll get some a
lot of nice editor services at that
point as far as running the program
typically you can't run programs that
still have holes in the compiler treats
them as a compiler error there is a
there is a feature of GHC that allows
you to pass in flag defer typed holes
and it'll run the program but it'll kind
of treat each to each of these holes as
rays on implementing it'll it'll crash
as soon as you get to that first hole
that you see so it's kind of a partial
solution to running the program but it
doesn't solve that problem of like
getting added live editor services at
points in the program that you don't
necessarily reach through that protocol
so what hazel is is an attempt to really
it's it's a hole oriented approach but
it tries to really do an end-to-end
solution to this gap problem so that
throughout the process of programming
you have a live typed program with holes
in it you never have just some text you
never have just a parse tree without a
type tree and you never have something
that stops prematurely because it hit
one of these holes and the key so so
what that implies is that all of these
editor services are available every
moment that you're using hazel there
isn't one millisecond we're one of these
editor services is off our somehow using
some heuristics or something like that
to kind of partially stay on which some
advanced programming environments do and
the key idea behind this is that instead
of making text edit actions the primary
way you edit programs we have this
language of structural edit actions and
their type aware and so so
structure editor there's many different
names for this projection alleged or
structured editor whatever you want to
call it but I don't really like any of
those phrases because as you'll see in
my demo in a second I really try to want
I'm really making the hazel you I try to
feel as much like these existing things
that I just showed you feel like text
and I really want you to think about it
as just automatic whole insertion right
instead of having to go do it yourself
the programming environment always puts
it in for you it saves you time and
again it gives you this end-to-end
guarantee you there's no gaps in this in
this pipeline so I want to switch to a
demo a real quick this is gonna be a
little tricky because I have to look at
this screen okay so this is the hazel UI
like I said hazel is experimental the
language of hazel is the simply typed
lambda calculus with a few extensions so
a very popular very practical
programming language in my opinion and
what you start with is a whole and each
hole has a name and in the hazel UI we
just use numbers for names this is hole
one let me zoom in a little bit is this
is that okay can everyone see that in
the back yeah okay so you start with
hole one and your cursor is on it and
you can start typing two plus so if I
type two plus you don't get a parse
error you don't get any sort of weird
intermediate like error recovery thing
going on it just inserts a hole for you
right there in the program hole two and
and you can see it the result there's a
result computed and there's a type
computed that says a result of type num
and the result is two plus whole to the
colon 1 means instance one of hole -
I'll show you examples of programs where
you don't get multiple instances of a
single hole from the source program in a
second and if you look at the at the top
right there there's this thing called it
the type inspector and it tells you that
at the current cursor position where
you're in a hole they're expecting
something of type num and you're getting
something of a consistent type question
mark and so there's actually holes and
types as well in hazel
and we use this notion of type
consistency which comes from the work on
gradual typing so gradual typing was
sort of originated in this in the world
of like untyped dynamic languages that
you are slowly annotating but here they
are just coming very useful in this very
different domain of editing programs and
not just at not having enough
information to know what that hole is
gonna be filled with okay so we can type
two here and get our answer for I didn't
have to press ENTER or anything it's
evaluating on every edit now um so this
you know so if you've seen structure
editors before this kind of thing might
not be that that not interesting and I
think the usual complaint is that didn't
we try structure editors in the 80s
right like and then they failed and text
turns out to be the best thing I don't
know maybe like I don't have data about
hazel for you but maybe we will one day
but we're doing some things from some
more recent structure editors like MPs
and better to really make this structure
editor thing feel more like automatic
whole insertion and less like AST
transformations where you have to have a
mental model of the ast and you're doing
these local transformations so for
example if I if I go back here and I
type x three and then so in an
old-school structure editor if you plus
if you press plus here what that might
mean is like transform the selected node
into a plus node and so you'd get like
two plus friends three plus whole in
hazel if you press plus you get 2 times
3 plus whole but it associates the way
you would expect in a normal program
normal non in this programming language
and and yeah so it's doing this kind of
dynamic like every time we represent
operator sequences as just sequences and
where every time the sequence changes
they
it does reassociation according to the
usual order of operations and everything
like that so yeah so you can do things
like delete the delete the plus if it
becomes if I do plus four here so if I
yeah so if I delete the plus and there's
a hole there well it's like well pretend
nothing was there and just get rid of
the whole class there's a four there and
I do delete the plus then it's just
deleting the plus and it's reassociate
apply three as a function to four
because that's how that's how the
precedence works if you go over to the
three you'll see that it's in this
dotted red box and that's a non-empty
hole so that's not just part of the user
interface of hazel that's part of the
semantics of hazel that red box that's
the non empty hole that we assign
meaning to so you can see in the result
there's also a red box with a three on
it oh wait a three in it and then
there's some stuff those are casts I
wanted to put a text box in right before
the talk was given to hide those but I
thought I would actually mention them as
there's what's it what's actually going
on here is if you look at the right side
bar up there it says expecting something
a function type or in function position
got something of type num but it's in a
hole so I'm gonna treat it as this hole
arrow whole kind of thing temporarily
and when you have holes in types you can
do weird things this is from this
gradual typing you can start writing
programs that have dynamic errors again
and so these things are the casts they
come from the cast calculus which is
part of the theory of gradual typing and
they're used to ensure type safety and
ensure that you don't get stuck you'll
actually get a cast failure but when a
cast fails it doesn't cause program
execution to stop it will actually kind
of treat it as a dynamically generated
whole and continue as if it was a static
whole so I'll skip actually showing that
to you it's not that interesting I'll
show you something else
so I showed you a valuation of like
sub-expressions right if you do two
times three plus you get six plus whole
14 instance one right so you're getting
this computation of two times three is
actually happening even though you have
a hole there and that's that's true even
if you put the hole on in on the left
side right so if you do this plus two
times three you get whole sixteen plus
six as well
right so it's not stopping you know
assuming left to right evaluation of
these things it's not stopping because
it sees hole 16 it's just kind of
leaving it as this residual or some
indeterminate kind of expression that
you can't case analyze on but you can do
other stuff elsewhere in the program
right there's also maybe you have many
tests that you're running and one of
them has a hole or something in it why
do you have to stop you're you know what
you have to do something with a test run
are very complicated right just keep
going
c1 puzzled face you can ask questions on
slide oh okay and then I already showed
you the site bears there's also you can
also write down free variables so if for
example if I if I can put a space here
first if I want but I don't have to if I
put enough in there it'll say hey
there's nothing named after your in your
context expecting something a function
type got this free variable F but I'm
treating it like it's a hole just like
with a non-empty hole and I'll have T
holes different than a free variable
because a non empty hole has something
well typed in it just maybe not of the
right type so it like reifies typing
consistencies free variable holes are
similar but they ratify binding airs
like unbound variable errors and the
thing inside an unbound variable error
is a free variable it's not well typed
because it's not in the context all
right so let's actually do let's show
you some binding so let's define this
function f and again when I did a let it
put the holes in into the right place
I'm gonna make a lambda and I'm going to
make it like an AA marrow Nam arrow num
and those are just in fix operators
there I can go back to this hole here
and maybe make another
do X plus y plus whole okay whoa line
wrapping there my 3d printers not that
great right now but and then let's apply
that that a couple of times so let's
call I got fine two plus two and then
let's look at what's going on and in
this hall at the end of the program here
so the result isn't that interesting
right it just says well this whole thing
evaluates the whole 33 because you just
did some bindings and then ended it a
whole there's nothing good put at the
end but if you look there at the sidebar
which I cannot see it all from here okay
sorry so there's a you have all the
bindings in scope right you have F of
this type no marrow no meronym have a of
technology if type num and you also have
values for those bindings so the value
of F is this lambda and annotated lambda
there and then you have these these
computations that actually did the like
2 + 2 + + + 3 and add the 4 + 3 and you
get that 7 same thing with B and then
you get two instances of whole 27
instance 2 + 3 and since 1 is the
instance that's in the original function
body and so yeah so you so this is
called we're doing what's called what we
call hole closure tracking so when
you're evaluating a hole you don't just
evaluate it as just like this symbol you
actually implicitly are like invisibly I
guess I want to say the there's a an
environment that's associated with each
hole and when that holds being holes
evaluated it kind of captures the
environment that that was there when
that hole was evaluated and you can go
and
where's my cursor
right yeah okay you can go and click on
one of these if you want and it'll take
you to the corresponding hole in the
program and now you'll see the context
of that point in the program where is
just x and y are bound of type num and
you'll see their values from that hole
closure that you selected so this is
this is the first closure the first
instance of hole 27 which was produced
when from that first call at bound
variable a and you can you can actually
toggle between all the instances of the
hole that are in the results so you can
start seeing all the values that came in
to this hole and that can help you
concretely think about what values are
coming into your function instead of
just thinking abstract lis in terms of
what their type r type is and so
assuming your types aren't like
singleton types this I think it's quite
useful and then yeah you can do the
usual thing like you can fill this hole
here at the end with like a plus B and
you'll see that those hole instances are
now not in the sidebar anymore you don't
get these holes you don't get this hole
closure information at all times because
it's associated with the hole that
you're currently in and that's that
really it means that there's the
overhead of this mechanism is far lower
than like recording all calls to a
function it's only exactly the holes
that you have in the program there's any
recording going on so there's no
overhead when you have a complete
program at all right which he hasn't
downsize you could like I think tracing
is a complimentary mechanism to this I
wanted to say that anyway so yeah so you
have these hole instances in the and the
result now instead of in the sidebar but
you can do the same thing click on them
toggle between them and go back to the
hole
and see the closure information okay so
yeah so that's all I want to kind of
show you in the in the hazel UI you can
play with this thing oh oh yeah there's
another thing I wanted to show you if
you hover over these infix operators
you'll see that how they're how they're
being associated I don't know how well
that comes across on the screen but like
the darker the background there the
tighter of the Association so we're
really taking advantage of having a
syntax tree information
and this could be useful when you have
more complicated operators and things
okay so now I want to go back to this so
yeah so you can go to hazel dot org and
play with that we're doing yeah so so
that language is very simple it's a
simply typed lambda calculus there's
sums and numbers and things but it's not
very usable so our our next step in
terms of the implementation over the
next step hopefully two months three
months is to kind of scale this up
we're targeting elem or something very
close to Elm maybe maybe Elm and yeah
and then you know I think the the the
this idea that we have for the UI is
basically to make it as text like as
possible while maintaining this
invariant about no gaps and so you know
that's not entire it's not entirely text
like yet but we're really working on it
and we have this idea of using holes in
another way which is if you do want to
get completely out of the structure
editing world for a little part of your
program because you're doing something
quite strange then we have this idea of
a text editing editing hole where you
can select a node turn it into a hole
and what's inside the hole is just some
text and then you have an action when
you're done editing that text using text
edit actions to turn it back into a
structured program and so it's not like
you have to go into your other editor
and edit the whole program in text and
then come back we want to do that very
locally it's not implemented yet but
we're working on it we have a textual
syntax for hazel now but it's not in the
UI yet and yeah our goal is to use hazel
in some part of our keep so I'm an
academic my I'm a postdoc and my advisor
Ravi at Chicago and then my collaborator
Matt at Boulder they both teach
introduction to functional programming
courses to to undergraduates
Ravi uses elm and a little bit of
Haskell and and Matt uses oh camel and
so we're we're giving some serious
thought to using this for some part of
that course initially I think we're
going to use it as the instructors of
the course during lecture because often
what you do when you're teaching when
you're
you're going through an example as
you're saying okay we've like gotten
this far and we need to fill what should
we fill this hole in in with you know I
know and then you go I'll wait and then
you wait for somebody to answer right
and and they're just their minds are
usually just kind of blank and no one
answers and and so you can help them by
pointing out that sidebar that says what
the expected type is and then you can
ask them questions about what's in scope
that might be of that type and things
like that so I think using it as a
lecturer is kind of a nice initial
application and then eventually we want
them to actually use it in homework
assignments and and then down the line
other applications that probably a lot
of you have in mind and are thinking of
reasons why this never work okay my
slides are cut off a little bit that's
okay
it just says cue there on the left so um
I want to give you a feel of what this
might look like once we have element
limited this isn't quite Elm but it's
almost done so this is kind of a mock-up
that we generated kind of an encoding of
this program in in in hazel and then
like cleaning it up quite a bit to make
it presentable and so we're implementing
quicksort here and if you recall
quicksort it is a recursive function it
takes a list and in the empty case it
returns the empty list obviously and
then it it picks the pivot is the head
of the element in this case and then it
calls this partition function that like
turns that they let the the rest of the
list in to-do lists smaller and bigger
that contained the elements that are
smaller and bigger than the pivot and
then you do recursive calls to sort
those things and then you got to do
something to combine them and so you're
in this hole that's in the return
position after you've done some like
recursive computations and and at the
bottom there we've called quicksort on a
little example list so again the results
of this computation according to our
little dynamic semantics there's just
whole one all that does is it confirms
that we went through the recursive case
of this function when we have a
non-empty input which is small pieces of
information but not that interesting
what's more interesting is that sidebar
and that sidebar shows you what the
pivot is on the sort of outermost
recursive call there it shows you what
the tail of the list is X is it shows
you with the result of calling small of
the partition function is smaller and
bigger and it shows you the result of
the recursive calls which again are just
hole instances but those hole instances
are different instances instance does
that say 2 & 3 instead of 1 and you can
click on instance 3 for example and and
dive into that recursive call on the
bigger list and then you'll see this the
bigger list starts with 6 and the rest
of it is 5 & 7 and the recursive calls
just give you 5 and 7 and then you'll
see ok well you're rehearsing on this
one element list it happens when you do
that click again and smaller this time
for example and you'll see these base
cases and then you're kind of done so
you've you've traced through this
recursive computation but you haven't
done this tracing of like all function
calls because that would be kind of
confusing like which one of the like 7
calls to this function were was the call
to like the huge sort bigger from the
outer recursive call you're just gonna
get like all the all the data that was
recorded and you require some pretty
sophisticated like debugging stepping
through the evaluation tray stuff to it
to really understand this all of this
stuff that I'm showing you is all
relative to the result the result
contains a hole and that hole has a
closure and in that closure is some
other holes that themselves have
closures and we're just showing them
this is recursive closure structure to
you sort of iteratively by or
interactively in this sidebar and so
it's a nice way I think to understand
these recursive computations and if
you'll notice at the very bottom there
it tells you the paths that you took so
if you forget what you clicked on it
says you started at hole 1 1 and then
you selected hole 1 2 from which is
somewhere in our bigger variable in that
environment in that closure and then our
smaller so you so you can actually kind
of navigate back and forth and again
this is something that I can imagine
using as a
sure but also maybe you can imagine
using for something okay now for the
terrifying bit if we haven't been
spending the last two years
implementing Elam if it is just a simply
typed lambda calculus with this kind of
silly user interface promising but silly
user interface what have we been doing
what we've been doing is we've been
really working out the type theoretic
foundations for everything that I just
showed you and so I'm not going to show
you all the inference rules and all that
stuff but I just want to point out like
this is what the simply typed lambda
calculus with holes what's what its
grammar looks like so here we have our
empty hole it's hot dogs with use on
them use the hole name a hot dog is the
hole and the reason it's a hot dog is
because I use tech and because I want to
have this non empty hole or something in
between the buns and that's the non
empty hole and I didn't make any hole
jokes but I am making hot dog jokes and
then we also have type holes and again I
mentioned earlier but it's to reiterate
type holes behave exactly like gradual
typing unknown the unknown type and
gradual typing so there's this notion of
type consistency that came from a great
paper by Jeremy seek and welly Taha and
we use that same notion to allow you to
put something of type hole where there's
something of any other type and that's
expected there it's a little bit like
subtyping but it's not subtyping it has
different properties so and then so yeah
tau is the type sees the expressions DS
are the runtime expressions and they
have to they're a little different
because they have these castes in them
that's what the cat the first one there
that's highlighted is the caste form
again from the gradual typing literature
the second form is the form for failed
castes and this is what's kind of
different from gradual typing is we
actually represent failed castes as
terms instead of as like part of the
semantics that cause evaluation is
stopped and so these behave much like
holes that are generated at runtime
and then the runtime representation of
holes it looks much like the surface
representation of holes but there's this
thing Sigma and that thing Sigma is the
environment disclosure so like a whole
instance plus a closure is as is what's
represented there and we you can
actually connect this to this theory
called contextual modal type theory
which is a proof theoretic
interpretation of actual modal logic and
you know I'm not going to go into what
that means but it's this nice theory of
like meta variables which are different
from variables because they're given
meaning by this conceptual substitution
operation which instantiates the free
variables with these substitutions Sigma
and what that does is it gives us is
really nice like logical interpretation
of that whole closure stuff that I
showed you and in the UI so I just want
to point out that there's a lot of
beautiful theory beautiful connections
to logic and and theory can be done not
on just programs but on programming
environments and editor services and
things like that so that's what the
point of this was okay so
okay so um this doesn't quite solve the
gap problem that that I told you about
just the static and dynamic semantics
for this grammar because you can still
write terms in this grammar that aren't
well typed that don't have the holes in
the right place the non empty holes for
example in the right place this doesn't
have the free variable holes but we
added those recently and so to really
get that gap problem to be solved you
also need a semantics of edit actions
these things that I was doing typing
what's the meaning of an edit action and
we have a theory for edit actions as
well and I won't show you any of the
like really gritty details of that but
I'll just point it out with this diagram
there's these added actions alpha and as
you go along you you perform these edit
actions in some way and then the edit
states are not just expressions they're
expressions that have types and that hat
on the e means this is also a
representation of the cursor and a
guarantee is that the Edit actions is
we've defined them maintain this well
type in this invariant that they in stay
themselves insert the non empty holes in
the right place so that you can always
reason statically according to our
semantics about every editor state and
so we actually prove that as a meta
theorem that's just what PL people call
theorems about programming languages we
call it sensibility and it just means
every edit action leaves the Edit State
well typed and we prove this and a lot
of a lot of other properties using act I
so this is a programming environment
that we've proven properties about the
Edit action semantics and the meaning of
incomplete programs for and we call that
hazelnut that cold core calculus so
hazel is an extension of hazelnut you
don't have all these editor services
obviously implemented we have some of
them in some form but the key ideas are
all in hazelnut right like you can
reason statically from recent
dynamically you have this language of
structured type where edit actions and
yeah so that's that's the sort of
current state of hazel I want to now
talk a little bit about some of the
ongoing and future work that we have
planned which there's a lot of stuff one
thing is that actions in in the system
right now are very low-level so how do
we define higher-level added actions for
example how do we find refactorings and
other
program transformations that we can
invoke in the editor how do we do
various domain-specific added actions
like we could imagine some edit action
like so a cool example in this paper by
June cor cut at tidy tide tidy yesterday
or two days ago or something like an
edit action that simplifies a right acts
right in the editor so that was pretty
cool our group at Chicago Bryan Hempel
and a bunch of others are working on
this thing called sketch sketch with
someone you might know about and they
have a lot of really cool ideas for
high-level edit actions as well and so
what is the semantics of that in terms
of low-level edit actions and then once
you have higher-level added actions how
do you do good like code completion or
or more generally how do you suggest
good edit actions to the programmer in
an intelligent way so I'm sort of
generalizing the idea of code completion
or program since this is I'm saying you
don't want to just synthesize code to
fill a hole with you want to synthesize
edit actions you want to suggest that
maybe you should do a refactoring
suggest that maybe you should move
somewhere else because that might help
answer a question that you have right
you might want to move to the next hole
or the previous hole or something like
that can that be a part of the
suggestion box and also you can
incorporate some of this live into this
closure information directly into the
suggestion box and see what this like
hypothetical hole filling would actually
evaluate to in the current closure and
then maybe we could use machine learning
and actually incorporate both like
statics like semantic information and
learned information about idioms from
from code core purposes into the
suggestions that are generated and so
having a theory of incomplete programs
allows us to really imagine doing that
in a good way so far I've been sort of
giving you this idea of you hilt you
fill holes by doing these like it feels
very much like coding right like writing
text like stuff but in some cases for
some data types it's a lot more natural
to construct a value of that type by
direct manipulation of a GUI for example
if you have a list of student records
where that's just a record containing
five five fields with grades and names
and stuff in it it'd be nice if we could
construct a value of that type using an
actual like grid and something like an
Excel user interface and so we're
working on this idea called palettes
which allows you to
do hole filling by direct manipulation
of a GUI that's sort of custom custom Li
defined for that type and that GUI
itself can have holes in it that you can
fill with expressions so it's not that
once you get out of the textual world
you're permanently in the graphical
world and you can never go back you can
go into the graphical world and then
back into the textual world and maybe
fill one of these holes with another
another palette and so it's this very
compositional view of gooeys is not
things that are generated by running a
program but that are part of your
program and maybe for certain users you
just hide all the code and just give
them the GUI but underneath they're
actually programming actually generating
code and then further down on the page
you actually have a value of type list
student rec that you can call map on you
can call you can fold over and all that
stuff you can imagine more
domain-specific examples of this like
you're trying to do grade cut-offs
clearly in academic with my examples and
yeah you want to kind of do these
sliders for where these and these are
and and there we want to actually see
some data in the GUI and so we don't
want to just fill this like data at the
hole with the expression weighted
averages and then like blindly selecting
but we want to see the actual value of
weighted averages and we have this hole
closure stuff right we actually have
some values we can use we can actually
give the GUI these actual values and you
can select a different closure and the
GUI will change and so we're working on
this sort of live holes direct
manipulation gooeys with holes thing and
I've done a bunch of related work on
that I just want to briefly mention it
in in eclipse a few years ago I did a
very similar thing you can construct for
example here a reg ax value in Java with
a GUI for constructing reg X's with a
bunch of helpful things in it tests test
Runner and stuff like that and so that
doesn't that doesn't actually have holes
in it that's just a string box and you
can't put sub expressions in there
earlier this week at I CFP I talked
about this work on typed literal macros
and that's in a purely textual setting
in the reason language which is a
variant textual variant of oh camel but
there you can define custom notation for
a data type like reg ax and then do this
thing call it which we called splicing
there allows you to put sub expressions
in it and splicing is really putting a
hole in a custom
and so this Palace idea is kind of
combining that the graphite thing I just
showed you on the previous slide with
this idea of putting it in a graphical
setting and adding live programming to
it in a certain sense okay
I'll stop talking about that my favorite
project I'm working on right now
the other thing that I haven't mentioned
is there are certain editor states that
are malformed not because there's a
missing expression or an old typed
expression but because like it's this
weird thing that gets generated and it
has conflicts in it and those like and
the editors like I don't know what seven
equals means is that some weird
JavaScript thing I don't know about and
it puts an error thing underneath and so
like what if instead of representing
these things is just taxed be
represented these conflicts as like
holes with multiple things in them and
said okay I don't know what you want to
fill this with but here are some options
from the different branches and stuff so
that would be one option and I think
that's a good idea we're also just
thinking more generally about
collaborative editing in hazel and and
the really the the key idea for that is
inst what if instead of representing
differences between different versions
of your programs if your program is a
structural diff of the program what if
you represented as the sequence of edit
actions that caused you to go from the
first to the second version that would
be a different point of view on it and
we also think there's this question of
CRT T's which is a notion it looks like
a data structure in the distributed
systems community that has this property
that like the operations on it can come
in in any order and you get the same
result so the simplest example is like
an increment only counter doesn't matter
where you know in which order the
increments come in you get the same sum
at the end and so what if we could
define a system where the actual program
is like type expression in the lambda
calculus or something more complicated
was a CR DT where the actions were
defined such that they could come in in
any order and you'd get an equivalent
result so that's not trivial but we have
some ideas about how you could actually
do that and really simplify the notion
of collaborative editing and an
inversion a by having this
convergence property where you don't
have to do diffs you just use these
conflict holes sometimes when it's
necessary and those can be resolved so
there's like a tons of other ideas I you
know I love talking about editors I know
people have lots of opinions about
editors what I really want to conclude
with here is this kind of vision that we
have of like imagine a computational
Wikipedia where pages weren't just like
text and images but they contain values
of a type functional programming
language and you thought I have the
whole Wikipedia computational capito as
a single program being collaboratively
edited by tap hundreds of people using a
state of the art semantic editor like
this and and like the gap problem would
be really serious if you did that
naively right because anyone writing to
Plus anywhere would cause the whole wiki
to become meaningless and so solving the
gap problem I think really enables this
vision and I'm gonna conclude with just
an invitation let's build this together
I can't you know like we have a small
academic team but we're totally open to
collaborating with anyone who's
interested on the on on all this kind of
stuff we have a website I'm on Twitter
and I'd be happy to take questions and
I'll switch to slide Oh
[Applause]